so i have a curve here that represents y
is equal to f of x and there's a classic
problem that mathematicians have long
thought about how do we find the area
under this curve maybe under the curve
and above the x-axis and let's say
between two boundaries let's say between
x is equal to a
and x is equal to b
so let me draw these boundaries right
over here that's our left boundary this
is our
right boundary and we want to think
about this area right over here
well without calculus you can actually
get better and better approximations for
it how would you do it well you could
divide this section into a bunch of
delta x's that go from a to b they could
be equal sections or not but let's just
say for the sake of visualizations i'm
going to draw roughly equal sections
here so that's the first
that's the second
this is the third this is the fourth
this is the fifth and then we have the
sixth right over here
and so each of these this is delta x
let's just call that delta x one this is
delta x two this width right over here
this is delta x
three all the way to delta x
n i'll try to be general here and so
what we could do is let's try to sum up
the area of the rectangles defined here
and we could make the height maybe we
make the height
the based on the value of the function
at the right bound it doesn't have to be
it could be the value of the function
someplace in this delta x but that's one
solution we're going to go into a lot
more depth into it in future videos
and so we
we do that
and so now we have an approximation or
we could say look the area of each of
these rectangles are going to be f of x
sub i or maybe x sub i is the right
boundary the way i've drawn it times
delta
x i
that's each of these rectangles and then
we can sum them up
and that would give us an approximation
for the area
but as long as we use a finite number we
might say well we can always get better
by making our delta x is smaller and
then by having more depth more of these
rectangles
or get to a situation here we're going
from
i is equal to 1 to i is equal to n
but what happens is delta x gets thinner
and thinner and thinner and we have an n
gets larger and larger and larger as
delta x gets infinitesimally small and
then as n approaches infinity and so
you're probably sensing something then
maybe we could think about
the limit
as we could say as n approaches infinity
or the limit as delta x becomes very
very very very small and this notion of
getting better and better approximations
as we take the limit as n approaches
infinity
this is the core idea of integral
calculus
and it's called integral calculus
because the central operation we use the
summing up of an infinite number of
infinitesimally thin things is one way
to visualize it is the integral that
this is going to be the integral in this
case from a to b and we're going to
learn a lot more depth in this case it
is a definite integral of
f of x
f of x dx but you can already see the
parallels here you can view the integral
sign as like a sigma notation as a
summation sign but instead of taking the
sum of a discrete number of things
you're taking the sum of an infinite
an infinite number infinitely thin
things
instead of delta x you now have dx
infinitesimally small things
and this is the notion of an integral so
this right over here is an integral
now what makes it interesting to
calculus it is using this notion of a
limit but what makes it even more
powerful is it's connected to the notion
of a derivative which is one of these
beautiful things in mathematics as we
will see in the fundamental theorem of
calculus that integration the notion of
an integral is closely tied closely to
the notion of a derivative in fact the
notion of an antiderivative in
differential calculus we looked at the
problem of hey if i have some function i
can take its derivative and i can get
the derivative of the function
integral calculus we're going to be
doing a lot of well what if we start
with a derivative can we figure out
through
integration can we figure out its
antiderivative or the function whose
derivative it is as we will see
all of these are related the idea of the
area under of curve the idea of a limit
of summing an infinite number of
infinitely things than things and the
notion of an anti-derivative they all
come together in our journey in integral
calculus